oh my goodness real tears real actual
tears Prince what's going on everybody
for first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones the show with
hot questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by the Giants defensive
back Prince Amukamara Prince Prince I'm
up Amaka Amukamara Prince Amukamara
Prince Amukamara is that right yeah
people mess it up all the time
uh yeah yeah and it's funny cuz if you
actually read it it's you say how it's
big if you're not a sound stuff Prince
Amukamara so we have 10 questions 10
wings and 10 sauces as we go along in
the interview the sauces get hot like
very very hot the mic gets so hot that
you have to throw in the towel you're
midseason you're just a couple days
removed from jumping around on Kirk
Cousins we don't want to put you on the
DL or anything so if you have to tap out
just throw in the towel say I'm done I
can't do it anymore
and jump right to the last question but
there's a catch at the end if you can
make it all the way through and eat all
10 wings
you get 30 seconds of uninterrupted time
to plug whatever you want the floor is
just Wars you know what I mean but if
you don't make it through take a third
floor and it's a bit of a subplot
everybody has made it through except for
Tony so far Tony Yayo is all the only
person to ever kappa so that would be
the company that you're instigating ok
just to make you aware so you ready to
go right yeah I'm ready to move all
right Prince here are your hot ones
now the first one is just Texas Pete hot
sauce and this one's easy
this is the by week of hot sauce with
Chicago Bears and hot sauce is ready and
I can fire that shot because I'm from
there so and I have to watch my team
every Sunday
question what would surprise people not
be like it well this is still as much
your anyway um I would say he has a
great sense of humor until after you see
they they see it on the commercials but
it goes beyond the essays running
funnies buzzing he just pulls definitely
I can give an example but he would just
pull like just some type of prints on
you and it's being feel I would pool I
heard that about Eli he's like a little
bit of prankster number two flew a hot
sauce I can not that big a deal like I
know you don't get to show it off a lot
in the end zone you play on the
defensive side of the ball right but I
saw you propose to your wife with the
Jabberwock oh I know that you can dance
a little bit if you had to rank the best
answers to worst answers you Victor Cruz
Odell Beckham jr. where we can put them
because all I've seen Victor do is also
could be the last of the group I would
say we know Delta Pi b1 a1 we can't do
that you gotta go on uh we had Joe doubt
yeah but it probably a patio doe dose of
dough showing so many dance moves and so
personal
okay err number three
oh you can't echo Caribbean habanero
kind of like a fruity flavor on this one
right I travel made some headlines last
year when he said that you got your swag
back because you got married and
consequently lost your virginity and
then you were having sex so that's why
you were playing right is that a pretty
good summation go through odds when you
said but that kind of goes against
everything that I've always been taught
where you'll have World Cup teams
completely abstain from sex or you'll
have white boxers that stayed from sex
Russell Wilson abstain from sex so so as
someone who's been through both schools
which is it like is it easier to play
when you've had sex when you're not
having sex is there no difference at all
oh I've had sex before I played enough I
I didn't have sex before I played in I
don't think it it altered my performance
in any way so no difference whatsoever
different so if you're a boxer and
you're AB staining you don't need to
know pixal old wives tale you're a
legend got it all right number four
lottie's traditional Barbados hot sauce
kind of like a mustard thing going on
with it this one of me is just like
straight up good mm-hmm
for the third year in a row hummus is
the official dip of the NFL wouldn't you
think of that have you ever seen honest
at a tailgate you ever seen hummus on
the table like you might have one weird
CrossFit friend that brings hummus right
but other than that does that seem odd
to you I never knew that my wife loves
love summer so so that's even how I know
the word and um I don't know I don't
know how that's positive
and debug it how that goes this next one
pain is good louisiana-style
it's kind of like a habanero jalapeno
sort of mix okay and this one it's like
not so bad even though pains in the
title it's the next one where it's hey
what do you think's a better franchise
The Bachelor of the Bachelorette
what do you mean by better franchise
like what would you rather watch The
Bachelor would you rather watch girls oh
you could blindside you right there all
right back Steve Wow no joke out here
you have the same sauce real tears real
actual tears Prince this is a hot ones
first more painful so far this in the
first quarter of a Thursday Night
Football
this of course battler Bachelorette
which would you be more excited to watch
um The Bachelor The Bachelor right I
like watching The Bachelorette do you
know why I like watching The
Bachelorette one because I like first
off I like watching guys be romantic
around girls the other thing is is it's
amazing to watch these guys collect like
get into a room and conspire to snitch
on another one a certain tree
you know what I mean yeah and I always
think about if I was in the show and
Kyle and chase came up to me in the like
yo we're gonna go tell on Gavin because
he says that he has a girlfriend back
home I'd be like what are we in fourth
grade but they do that every single
episode they tattle on I can see that
yeah I mean everyone everyone has the
same goal nuts to get on the coin has to
get nuts to get the girl at the end so I
guess it's no hos bars at
everything goes so they get when you're
trying to land that girl yeah so they
can all form alliances or whatever it
doesn't matter
yeah I've seen friends I just seem like
my friends pretend like they're playing
a chess game you know what I meant okay
well if you had trouble with that one
this next one is gonna be like easy no
oh the exact opposite okay this next one
is gonna it's gonna punch you right in
the mouth like this one to me is like
the second worst out of all of them to
me okay so this one is pain 100% hot
sauce technically two and a half times
hotter than a jalapeno but this one
catches it catches you ready what uh
what do you think like the most hostile
stadium like when you go and visit I
would say the most hostile place would
just be Twitter or just be Twitter or
like or like Instagram I think I think
those I think you get it way worse there
than you do in aiming in 1880 Stadium
because you act like you read it word
for word and you just keep rereading it
over and over again whether compared to
a stadium it's like they say something
in your and you kind of wonder did they
just really like say that you don't even
know but when you just read it it's like
it's just a memory like it stays it
stays in your head
do you finish yours this one this one
cent Machine Gun Kelly through the
ceiling
holy dick we're actually cruising
through Blair's original death sauce
six times hotter than a jalapeno you
know there's that it's a debate that's
that's kind of bubbled up in the UFC a
little bit but I'm wondering you know an
NFL player to chime in as well well
Ronda Rousey yeah
with Ronda Rousey um but specifically
this Nick Diaz suspension for five years
okay for five you thats what it was for
weed yeah five years Wow I thought was
just for like a match
no five years so the Roger Goodell of
UFC is like the Nevada State Athletic
Commission
Oh five years so like it wasn't from
Dana White wasn't from UFC is from like
you know the Nevada so that's why Floyd
chimed in Floyd chimed in Rhonda chimed
in but it brings up an interesting
debate where it's like should athletes
even be tested for marijuana at all you
know and I wonder what you think Prince
do you think NFL players should be
tested for marijuana since it is legal
in some states like I think in
Washington and in California I would say
um you should be able to do it since
it's legal in your state look this way
you ready to go in this wing my lips are
so big whatever it makes it hot is like
so my lips are just on on fire right now
so I think that might be the advantage I
have
now the advantage I think advantage you
have over me because my mouth is still
burning don't I didn't even think about
that but you're probably right because
the lips it's the worst part that's the
worst part the mouth like a Hansel it's
the lips so you're right if you do have
like more surface area than your family
I'm gonna have some problems
we don't have like heart or respiratory
problems do you wing number eight
Dave's temporary insanity hot sauce
question what is the last thing you saw
Tom Coughlin's smile or laugh about oh I
would say smile maybe our win Thursday
night I would say he's useful I would if
I were ready Golf I would bring him oh
my god make your nose one a little bit
are you doing better than you thought
you would worse than you thought you
would about what you thought you would
our next cover is gonna have Justin
Bieber on it okay
and he had really yeah and the interview
came out yesterday and it is like the
most quotable interview I've ever read
Justin Bieber just has these quotes out
there one after another and he had this
one quote in particular that I want to
bounce off of you and you can tell me
what you think it means if it holds an
okay ready so he was talking about his
own Christianity and he said you don't
need to go to church to be a Christian
if you go to Taco Bell that doesn't make
you a taco right you heard that quote
well that's so funny cuz I've read this
on the way on the way here just on
accident on Twitter yeah and on my right
I read his interview yeah so me and
Justin are pretty cool with the same
pastor's name is um Carl and add at this
church Hillsong in the city and on I
don't know if he said that what Carlos
says just because you go to Krispy Kreme
doesn't make you a donut you got a
church from Beaver uh we go to same
church yeah amazing
I found out them like twice not trying
to not turn to name dropper right that
time this is a name drop show and house
a house hanging out with Bieber you know
what so I met him I met him uh hung out
twice so I met him for the first time at
O at a 40/40 club jay-z spine down own
City and then
we met at like I said we both neutral
friends with the pastor crawl at his
house so plate of NBA 2k I'm sure I want
can't lose to get an athlete losing my
fever I don't care for the video game or
not
the trick is to just eat it fast this is
Dave's insanity it's 36 times hotter
than a jalapeno like what's your weight
room mentality if you're pushed to the
brink you don't feel like you can go
anymore but you need to do more like
what do you do you go somewhere mentally
what's the what's the move I don't know
I think I just block everything go and
just say okay just be strong and just
didn't just do it yeah just find that
spot do you maybe use any of those same
traits when you're trying to power
through a wing challenge um no no need
yeah yeah all right well this is the
last one and this one is like insane
first off congratulations to getting to
this point not everyone does and we also
have a tradition here where we dab the
last wing so we mean Deb I'll show you
so let me tell you about this sauce it's
Mad Dog 357 pure chili extract seventy
one point four times hotter than a
jalapeno okay serving everyone point
yeah did you do the math real quick now
what I mean about dab and it's important
that you pay attention here because you
go like this just
just like that it looks like when you
just try to get a groove out and then
you squeeze and then you just get too
little
that's exactly just it's a very
unsatisfying drop this is a man who's
dabbed up a wing before it looks like
good mechanics mechanics ready yeah you
do it over here and squat so we're gonna
cobol yolks and then it hits another
head that's the thing is it's like a
time bomb like it tastes like kind of
fruity at the beginning and so you think
you're in the clear and then it hits you
do you think Roger Goodell observes make
twice as much money as Aaron Rodgers oh
I'm trying to give you a political
answer but I can't even think of that
that's what the show doesn't blows them
it blows your your guardrails off and
you just let it go
that's why I hit Machine Gun Kelly I was
like I used up my retros he didn't want
to come in here new question yet yeah
cuz he couldn't think we're sinister
over here at hot ones nah but listen I
know he's your boss nobody wants to talk
like that listen rich over here I
wouldn't throw him under the bus but
those figures 44 million to 22 million
rogering dollars on Aaron Rodgers on the
other what do you think their skills are
different so
and Rogers gets paid by his performance
on the field I'm Roger Goodell from my
understanding it's paid by the owner so
when he gets like it the big TV deals
that we get him stuff like that he gets
a big cut on from that so do you think
he's good at his job I think he's doing
the best job he can he could do for the
shield for the NFL he's good
well you made it through hot ones always
a mess afterwards is always regret
regret for me signing on we got for the
guest coming in but now at least you've
reached the finish line and the floor is
yours
30 seconds Prince all you this is Prince
Amukamara follow me on all of my social
media accounts that's Facebook at Prince
Amukamara that's Prince Amukamara
that's Twitter at Prince Amukamara
Instagram at Prince Amukamara
I just appreciate hot ones hot ones I'm
a hot one if they won yeah since day one
I like it
thank you Thank You Man thanks for
coming in appreciate it
you